That's right The Hunger Games that was a
was a cinematic franchise
[Music]
once so the Hunger Games the ballot of
song birds and snakes is a it's a long
ass title Don't Be a Menace to South
Central While Drinking Your Juice in the
Hood not the longest I've heard though
it's a prequel to The Hunger Games
trilogy because in entertainment you got
to strike while the iron's hot if you
can't do that make a movie eight years
later why not I know it's based off a
book just saying I was I wasn't I saw
the poster in the theater I was like
isn't a new one and this movie will
hopefully and in some ways it does some
ways it doesn't shows how this seemingly
nice person will one day become a really
big [__] first of all it takes place
in the capital for the most part in the
other Hunger Games movies we got
glimpses of the capital we were still
outside eyes visiting the capital but we
never got a peak behind those closed
doors this is that Peak so you get
political Intrigue classism Hunger Games
has always had class class ISM but even
among the rich and Elite there are
subclasses among the classes take snow
for instance he's not the most popular
he's not the richest he's not the most
connected he still feels and seems like
the little fish among much bigger fish
in this Capital pond so that's just more
interesting to see it Through The Eyes
of a character like that even though the
tactics he learns will Aid him in mess
murder but still for the sake of
entertainment and it taking place in the
past I thought the capital of PanAm was
the most interesting version of the
capital of PanAm we've seen on screen
yet the technology isn't this futuristic
digital technology it's analog the tech
the sets all looks like mid-century
radio and television shows the
televisions are all CRTs I was
salivating at the thought of that Retro
Gaming experience but it's futuristic
sci-fi style technology woven into there
too and mid-century futuristic sci-fi
analog Tech that's just that's Peak to
me it's a very specific Vibe and
experience so this is the movie it's not
just call I don't want to call it the
rise of of President Snow because that's
not really what it is it's just
President Snow and how he was back when
but in terms of the World building this
is the chapter in Pan's history where
the Hunger Games became entertainment
the manipulative tactics of
entertainment what draws people in what
holds them there the original Hunger
Games trilogy we we just come into that
world when they've already figured it
out this is them figuring that out which
means in the world it's a less
interesting Hunger Games event but the
adaptation of making it more marketable
I thought that was the cool part not the
murder no the pr that was solid it's not
always about that and when that ends man
you feel it okay the acting as for the
acting Tom blle as snow he is the star
of the film and I thought he was great
and I suppose that is a testament to Tom
blle he still makes this character
although you know where he ends up you
know he's the biggest dick in the world
in Hunger Games he ends up there but for
the most part he makes us forget that he
shows us the human being that will one
day be lost another standout is Viola
Davis as I mean she's pretty much a mad
scientist in the movie no doubt she is
absolutely having fun with the role uh
shortly into it I was like she
overcooking it a bit little bit came
across cartoony at times not going to
deny it but I also can't deny that I
ended up having fun when the character
was on screen at first I was just kind
of feel like I was laughing at the
character and then I ended up laughing
with the character cuz well Viola day
she could sell room temperature flat
beer to someone she's that good at the
job she's the real backstory right there
I wonder know what happened to her
character Sid do experiments on her in
Final Fantasy 6 what happened why is she
crazy Peter Dinklage was great too the
guy who came up with The Hunger
Games what would that person feel on his
dayto day Peter Dinklage just we know I
don't need to sell Peter Dinklage we
know how great he is he brings that here
Rachel zaggler okay she has an amazing
voice every time she's singing in this
this movie it's clear why she was cast
other than that I felt she was
forgettable as [__] fitting this
November theme apparently of two weeks
in a row of Dollar Store characters she
just kind of felt like dollar store
catniss and granted with catniss you got
her backstory you knew where she was
coming from you knew why she was doing
this thing she actually was sacrificing
herself to save her sister it's easy to
get behind that but when the first
Hunger Games came out Jennifer Lawrence
did something special you know she made
it her own she stood out she had that
screen presence Rachel Ziggler's
character Lucy gray Lucy gray is just
she's a girl in this
movie cuz granted the movie as in the
script the adaptation could have done a
couple more things for her I was picking
a buddy's brain who read the book and I
was like okay this this scene spoiler
free but it has to do with her singing
in The Hunger Games and the way he broke
down the information control that PanAm
is known for that the capital is known
for I was like I could have gone for
more of that in the movie information
control and those futuristic sci-fi
dystopian Concepts that most certainly
absolutely definitely don't exist in our
world but you know that would be a scary
world in which they do exist but not
here and then the last act happens this
movie's broken up into three chapters
the last act a lot more boring than the
first two and it just rushed to the end
all this build up with characters and
friendships and character conflicts and
possible conflicts later and this is
where it's all going to go down and it
does technically speaking but again
there a difference between just doing
something fulfilling a checkbox and
hammering home the point not saying this
doesn't have a couple of emotional
moments Tom ble has a couple of great
scenes where you're like he is feeling
it and he's selling it however when the
movie wrapped up it it sprinted to the
end and I felt it cheaping the payoff
not just the payoff with some of the
support characters but the payoff with
snow himself he has gone from those
golden locks looking like the loved
child of Nicholas Holton Tom Felton to
looking for mom's spaghetti he's seen
some [__] he's been there he's seen the
things but I didn't feel it by the end
so I can't help but think this probably
would have been a better miniseries
actually once again for another week of
reviews let's talk about bad CGI which
to be fair VFX departments for these
movies work to the Bone underpaid I
absolutely get that VFX workers getting
boned over a side it happens it's
noticeable it's happening more and more
and it happens in here too there's one
scene particular I was like wow that is
the greenest of green screen so in the
end The Hunger Games The Ballad of song
so in the so in the end The Hunger Games
The Ballad of sng birds and snakes got
the title sweet for me I thought Tom ble
was great didn't need a backstory for
President Snow but among the young
President Snow backstory is the real
compelling backstory for me and that's
the building upon the Hunger Games but
there were other things that didn't work
for me that are kind of important like
the main supporting actress pretty much
the the third chapter which is kind of a
snoring comparison like how does the
third chapter feel so slow in its pacing
yet so rushed and fast to its execution
to the ending a true cinematic Paradox
my friends but by God they do it it
probably be a better time if you're
drunk yeah now it's a party all right so
the Hunger Games the ballot of song
birds and snakes have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see
more
[Music]
the end of this movie was so fast it was
such a rush felt like it was going to
get his head crushed by omn
man no